The correct answers were negative 2 3rds and positive 3 halves. Fantastic work
if you found these two answers. Factoring is one of those important skills that
will come up again and again, so let's make sure that we know how to do this.
I'm going to subtract 5x from both sides and 6 from both sides. I perform this
same operation on both sides and I'm just showing these two steps I want. This
leaves me with 0 on the left and 6x squared minus 5x minus 6 on the right. I
also know I want to subtract on both sides here since I want the x squared term
to have a positive coefficient. It's generally easiest to factor when this term
is positive. So, I've taken my equation and I've rewritten it up here to factor
this part of the equation we need to find the factors of negative 36 that sum to
negative 5. These numbers are negative 9 and positive 4, so we can rewrite our
middle term and factor it by grouping. This gives us factors of 3x plus 2 and 2x
minus 3. Now that the right-hand side of our equation is factored, we can use
the zero product property and set each factor equal to 0. Solving for x in this
equation will get x is equal to negative 2 3rds. And summing for x in this
equation will get x is equal to 3 halves. The last thing we want to do for our
solution set is to make sure we check the excluded values. We know for these
denominators, x cannot equal 0 or else we would have fractions that would be
undefined. Since both of these values are not 0, we can rest assured that this
is our correct answer.